A tragedy has struck as Hector discovers his
friend has overdosed.
How can she be saved?
Well first Hector must know what opioids are.
Say someone falls to the ground and hurts
her knee.
In this case the body will release what are
called endogenous opioids to help her out
against the pain.
These include endorphins, enkephalins and
dynorphin.
However, an opioid is anything that binds
to an opioid receptor.
Therefore there are opioids which come from
outside our body but interact with the opioid
receptors in the same way.
These are called exogenous opioids.
There are three opioid receptors to which
they bind: mu, delta and kappa receptors;
and they are all a part of a group of receptors
called G-protein coupled receptors or GPCR.
Let’s view a model of this.
This part is the receptor itself, with 7 helices
which go through the membrane.
On the outside of the cell, there is a cavity
to which an agonist, like an opioid, binds.
On the intracellular side, the receptor is
coupled to a G-protein, which has an alpha,
beta and gamma subunit.
When an agonist binds, the G protein activates.
The GDP molecule bound to the alpha subunit
is released and replaced with GTP.
The protein dissociates into the alpha subunit
and the beta-gamma subunit, both of which
can now interact with other protein pathways.
For example, alpha interacts with adenylyl
cyclase, and the alpha protein can stimulate
or inhibit, based on the type.
This enzyme uses ATP to produce cAMP. cAMP
is the secondary messenger, which is involved
in many different responses.
An opioid can use this mechanism to inhibit
this enzyme and then prevent pain signals.
Eventually, the body becomes dependent on
and tolerant of the drugs, leading the body
to want more.
Addictions often begin with prescription drugs,
and then go out of control.
This has led to an opioid crisis.
To prevent misuse, people must only take the
prescribed amount of drugs, not share medications
and stay educated on the opioid crisis.
It is important to solve this crisis because
as many as 128 people die each day from an
overdose in the U.S.
But how can Hector’s friend be saved from
an overdose?
An opioid is an agonist, but there are also
antagonists such as naloxone which can bind
to an opioid receptor in the same way, but
not affect the G protein.
Why is this important?
Well, now that it is bound to the receptor,
the opioid can no longer bind, preventing
its effects
Knowing this, it is possible for Hector to
save his friend’s life.
He just needs to be prepared and stay informed.